this is a map of San Francisco there's a
lot of plots on that you may be asking
what is that plotting well this is an
app where they plot the human feces that
are found on the Streets of San
Francisco and you see how almost the
whole thing is covered because that is
what has happened in one of the previous
greatest cities this country's ever had
when a communist dictator comes to town
then they cleaned up the streets they
lined the streets with Chinese flags
they didn't put American flags there
they cleaned everything up so they're
willing to do it for a communist
dictator but they're not will to do it
for their own